italian mayor has lashed out at the
european union blaming it for a
so-called genocide of refugees in the
mediterranean earlier this week more
than 800 african migrants were rescued
in italian waters they're now being
housed on the islands of lampedusa and
sicily
the mayor of palermo has lashed out at
both brussels and regional neighbors for
failing to help italy deal with what is
now that of a perpetual crisis
what is happening in the mediterranean
is a real genocide that weighs on the
conscience of european states and the
european union nobody is helping italy
why isn't malta helping
someone should tell malta that it's part
of the european union malta is acting in
a selfish and irresponsible way like all
other european states on may the 9th on
europe day i wrote a letter to the
president of the european commission
vondalen and then to the president of
the european parliament sasoli asking
for the establishment of a european
life-saving social service a way to
prevent thousands of people from dying
at sea
the number of undocumented migrants
arriving in italy has surged by more
than 150 since last year and 460
since 2019.
the european council has promised border
nations additional support but the mayor
of lampedusa says the eu's lack of
action is just causing needless deaths
in order to prevent loss of life and to
reduce pressure on european borders
mutually beneficial partnership in
cooperation with countries of origin and
transit will be intensified
international agreements are not
respected europe is doing nothing it has
no strategy to solve this problem in
europe we only talk about refugees there
is no strategy for all the economic
migrants who come to italy the problem
of migrants according to the search and
rescue plan regulations concerns all
states and not just italy
europe must enforce this regulation and
make other states help migrants as well
italy certainly cannot declare war on
malta if the un has asked all states to
speak up and solve the problem through
international agreements and if until
now the problem has never been addressed
by anyone it means there is no political
will to try to solve the problem of
migrants we've repeatedly said that the
problem is not being addressed by anyone
and if it is not addressed there will be
more deaths more landings and no end to
ngos helping migrants at sea
this is the pattern there is no solution
because no one wants to find it nothing
will ever change as long as things
remain like this